Oh
oh hi we're here it out of this world
it's a traveling exhibition of costumes
from television and film that's
currently here at the California Museum
in Sacramento one of the things about
movie costumes is when you see them up
on the big screen with all the benefits
of lighting and special-effects they
look absolutely amazing fantastic true
to life but it's when you get up close
and personal with these original costume
designs like you can at this exhibit
that you understand how costume
designers put them together from very
ordinary objects and materials sometimes
just stuff the head laying around
okay a little bit of science fiction
trivia for you in science fiction nobody
wears a shirt okay they have a lot of
technological innovations but nobody has
ever invented the shirt if you're not
wearing a unitard you're wearing a tunic
like William Shatner here yeah or he
could wear a tunic over a unitard which
is actually called a tuna tarde but
anyway moving right along the really
impressive thing about this particular
costume yes that's right it's not the
costume itself it's William Shatner's
amazing pit stains underneath the arm
holes of the tunic which like the man
himself are legendary and massive
all right seriously Christian Bale Adam
West no absolutely wrong there is only
one true Batman everyone knows that okay
yes George Clooney as seen in the 1997
film batman and robin now one thing
you're going to notice about this
particular Batman costume is uh is it is
it cold in here or or those are those
hard fat nipples why yes I believe they
are you just kind of a push one look a
little look at the button
okay seriously I just have to fanboy out
here for just a minute because look it's
the actual Holy Grail from indiana jones
and the last crusade like when he gets
the end of the movie and is a coal the
cup of the carpenter and the guys like
you chose poorly and it's grown knob
turning the dust and stuff oh man that
movie was awesome this is a special part
of the exhibit this is actually the
halloween costume that i made last year
i made this i cut this out myself at
while my mom had to help me because i
can't use scissors or anything no I'm
just kidding this is actually Gorn from
the original 1960s Star Trek series and
the thing is kids who grew up in the 60s
then Goren scared the crap out of them
but now to actually look at it I mean no
it's a in the age of Jerry Bruckheimer
CG and everything rubber masks heroes
just don't cut it anymore and quite
frankly is for that tunic I mean I live
in San Francisco I see people wearing
that down the street every day that is
not alien anymore trust me yeah ok you
know who would definitely not fit into
this leather jacket arnold
schwarzenegger arnold schwarzenegger in
fact you know they actually had to delay
the filming of the original terminator
by two days just because this leather
jacket was not was a little small up in
the up in the shoulders for the
governator who actually works in fact
here in sacramento so I mean I heard he
actually came by and they they wouldn't
let him wouldn't let him fry below
jacket on they did they let him try the
slave leia costume on though jahir was
um yeah I don't really know why he would
do that
holy cow it is Darth Vader like real
Darth Vader from the good movies that
people actually enjoy watching it's
crazy actually looking at this costume
here in the museum because you can find
out that it's actually the Darth Vader
costume was this pastiche of all these
different costume elements that they
kind of had lying around in the film
studio like that's a that's a German
helmet and a gas mask from a world war
two movie put on top of a monk's
ecclesiastical cape from religious films
with a leather biker suit underneath in
a medieval breastplate to top it all off
and what actually kind of looks like
some of these old soccer shin guards on
his feet you know actually standing here
next to this this legendary costume it's
really cool but at the same time it's
like it's not like it's that imposing or
anything but I mean just you know Darth
Vader whatever dark side of the force